c'è lo sai qual è il problema in realtà
io lo so che per cliccato su questo
video perché hai visto la copertina del
video è visto che mi stavo pagando
addossa allora hai detto ma clicchiamo
perché voglio vedere famiglietti si
chiami addosso non so che lei fatto ciò
che fai questo ragionamento ogni volta
che vedi ma [ __ ] tutti ragazzi e
poi meno deve solo video sono fa vj poi
ci sono particolarmente senza voce tra
l'altro mi sono svegliato così porca
[ __ ] e quindi ragazzi ho scelto il
gioco giusto da fare assolutamente un
horror con l'alcol street
ovviamente che fermi che così almeno mi
sento in camicia di forza e entro pino
il personaggio perfetto quindi ragazzi
del professore che possiamo cominciare
già da allora già sono senza voce
non so che cosa uscirà fuori non lo
voglio sapere iniziamo perché sto già
messo male in partenza che bello
regalare bellissimo farei video in
canottiera e fantastico presto spacebar
perfetta iniziarlo mancato di mortacci
tua
ok ci siamo là per la partenza è stata
epica mentre il tormenti horror game
sfir yen suisse traminer weiser perché
c'è scritto che parimenti devo morire
giovani video cisco far due metri senza
cagarmi adorava cose menù che menù del
cazzo vabbè got the darkness andiamo
nell'oscurità così almeno siamo contenti
complimenti per la partenza perché so
perfettamente come son finito qui eh lo
so comunque ragazzi siamo in c'è una
scala a chiocciola di andro nuts
presenza sui titoli in apertura fuori la
madonna psicologica laroni xperience ma
io la chiamerei di più cristo nate in
diretta experience più o meno taciti tua
madre che cos'è il titolo the mental
torment tua madre il torment [ __ ]
già si è visto due amiche hanno fatto
anche di episodi di sta roba che neanche
farmi la lista della spesa possa partire
grazie comunque complimenti del per i
titoli di coda molto bello c'è una carta
innalza della madonna riga riga checa
che chi è che sta cagando sangue da dal
soffitto giorno aereo che schifo mi sono
nel maestro dai ragazzi siamo in un mare
di roba schifosa che non son voglio
sapere che cos'è comunque c'è la
partenza è stata fantastica ragazze per
tu
io che cos'è la catena e l'ombra della
catena ma [ __ ] mi chiami solchi
ragazzo dolce e tragica l'ombra così un
mio dio mio partito al mouse non lo
trovi sia scontati al 22 tampax non
guardano ogni tanto però fa il cazzo che
va comunque le catene sono carine se non
fosse che sto facendo chuv chaffin un
bagno non proprio pulito salve sono fa
vj sono appena uscito da un mare di
merda se volete darmi un biscotto una
brioche gesù sei tu gesù gesù no non è
gesù cioè sono io sono io nel riflesso
che va beh più o meno gesù giorno
apriamo sega b oppure devo continuare a
vedermi nel riflesso no di qua permesso
ragazzi io sono sono fa vige vengo in
pace sono una persona tranquilla più o
meno allora non ho già voce vi prego
così è successo perché ho aperto cosa è
successo di strano io ragazzi ba dove
non so dove sto andando lo sappiatelo
comunque che cazzo non vedo un pene non
vedo un pene e magari accendesse la vera
[Musica]
ok siamo in una stanza leggermente
sporca di sangue ma ok torno indietro
comunque se la luce mi fa un altro
scherzo del genere giuro che la lancio
alla finestra piuttosto va beh di qua
dico è un'altra catena a terra io non
capito le catene che cazzo ci hanno
contro di me sto già si ma se devi
trovare per cortesia fallo fuori grazie
no no non ti spegne la nota volte ti
prego non ti spenti supplico ma scusate
un attimo non sembra una cosa
bruttissima o sono io che josty pensieri
orribili oppure va beh mi faccia
comunque ma hanno chiuso la porta in
faccia a sinistra anzi mi torniamo
indietro un'altra volta sei stati
trasmette di orgasmo re mi fa un piacere
grazie ma perfetto e smesso quando te
l'ho chiesto sei molto gentile è la
madonna quante strade ci sono ma se io
andassi ma c'è una nuda
c'è una nota davvero orcadi con la [ __ ]
[ __ ] che non sei altro sei pure nude
détente grossa però ce l'avevi bene ai
ragazzi perfetto avevo scoperto e
dichiara il sangue ok è stato grandioso
grazie di avermi dato questa incredibile
sorpresa tipo bumanche ott complimenti
torni indietro ragazzo è stato beh
comunque la tipa non era male se non
fosse che mi è saltata tipo al collo ma
sono dettagli quest ma non sa quante
strade ci sono cazzo non so cos'è ma di
sicuro non è gesù allora ragazzi non ho
capito dove sto andando c'era una tizia
che mi sa che cosa che ma che schifo
però ma può una donna avere piuttosto
sangue in corpo si può sto scherzando
può quante cazzo di volte l'ho detto che
non si fuma in casa quante quante no no
però le scale di sotto non regga vi
prego madonna che fumo ma che c'hai
stare trova dei cannati qua sotto
vabbè che la porta a cazzo è sfruttato
una porta che ha permesso a chi apre la
pa come ha fra le mani llanos aprire le
maniglie sono un [ __ ] bene mental
torment non si aprono le porte bello la
lascio la ragazzi dalla sola
ma forse là dentro non ci entro sì sì
permesso sennò fa vige mia primi aprite
la porta grazie io non voglio sapere che
cosa c'è dentro lo giuro guarda non mi
interessa ecco questa mi sembra più
tranquilla almeno qui
oggi non ho toccato un cazzo ragazza
senza i tampax è entrata va dentro per
caso no perché hai un bagno e allora
sarà sicuramente qua dentro un cesso se
sei andata in bagno è già un passo
avanti perché non è che possa di qua
stai facendo trasloco zia ragazzi dove
stiamo andando vi prego if you man and
day che a scegliere serie b cioè due
maire fake e che madonna è spaccata e
dolce della serie io non faccio l'amore
mio scopo porte ecco la cola tipa di
prima è una rovina lo ha capito il senso
di saba v'è dog e del letto sbarcate
sempre ottimi posso spostare un oggetto
in un horror di joe line un horror non
ho mai visto la possibilità di spostare
degli oggetti assurdo scusami zio non
volevo comunque a parte spostare oggetti
che mi fa stranissimo dovadola di qua
perfetto e [ __ ] sha la la la la la
[Musica]
è la madonna anche con sensore che figo
sì ma una persona che pulisce a terra la
potreste anche per buongiorno ascoltati
sì sì sì sì
senti se ti fermi bene si è chiusa la
porta ringraziando gesù cristo è stato
bello via del cazzo e loro va bene così
ragazzo è stato bello non voglio
conoscere quel tizio mi sta molto
simpatico anche una voce sublime devo
ammetterlo è esatto naturalmente mi ha
messo mi arrapato solo sentire il suo
verso o porca la merda ragazzi cè un
tifo nascosto e quei buongiorno dove
cazzo andato c'era un tipo cosa cazzo
serve sostanza niente c'è un cestino a
terra bene
scelsi e finisce sto gioco prima o poi
che mi sta leggermente indossando il caf
grazie no no no no no basta ste luci
basse
no no lega però dai cazzo di luci che
fenomeno ha visto basta battere le mani
ragazzi quando le luci sisma
ricordatevelo è che questo serve nella
vita reale
qua io continuo a uccidere stendini a
cazzo va beh vedo del sangue a terra non
è un buon segno ma va bene
ma il bar stadi la perfetto sconto zio
ti seguo perché ho bisogno di una
brioche anch'io che stamattina non ho
mangiato bravo avanti bravo che bei
jeans che c'hai mi piacciono di qua bene
non ho non chiudere non chiude bravo
bravo che se no no no non posso dire è
ma allora sei stronzo dentro proprio
pezzo di merda priest a bordo che mi
sbattono le porte di farsi maledetti
maleducati e togliete dal cazzo che deve
andare al bar grazie è molto gentile
grazie a dio 6 gol sangue ormai ho
capito che devo seguire il sangue perché
sono non son contento se fai meno
scenografia zio perché tanto capi piano
piano detto piano piano piano piano
piano piano vado in un corridoio di due
chilometri e mezzo se non c'è un cazzo
mi incazzo era meglio che non ci fosse
un cazzo in questo caso finito si può
riaccendere la luce grazie
porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok potevi semplicemente dirlo che non
poteva entrare andava bene uguale e va
beh ma non se grazie zio ben e
seriamente bene pronto pizza da quattro
formaggi nadia vola una specie siamo a
posto grazie a una cosa alla volta merda
o al telefono la luce che è che
[ __ ] una lei 2 grazie perfetto le
porte magari se non le apre in faccia e
meglio però vi prego basta andare giu
almeno su senti e ascolta fratello né
che posso tornare di ogni 4 secondi
nello schifo ma è chiuso mista tapia per
culo pre vuoi cazzo respiro macchiato
mai vallo presa troppo sul serio mi
sarebbero sempre sognato nella mia vita
di essere riempito fino al collo di
mestre credo che fosse uno dei miei
desideri più nascosti tra l'altro no no
no no è che cazzo sporca per la smetto
ragazzi sto morendo affogato nel maestro
porca la [ __ ] [ __ ] tua madre che
cazzo uno squalo lo squalo nel sangue ma
fatemi capire il senso perché uno squalo
dovrebbe prega ragazzo sfonda sto tizio
non ascolta chi donne la roba da
mangiare ma non sfonda sami va via via
via su madonna non ce l'hanno fatta a
sopravvivere non so come ho fatto
sopravvive sarò sporco dalla testa ai
piedi di sangue fotte sehgal importante
che sono fuori se sapevo portava gli
accendini anch'io no vabbè c'è una festa
a parte di scherzi sembra una faccia
sdentata vista così
fammi passare un attimo grazia c'è elba
è il boiler dell'acqua calda e scorso i
boiler dell'acqua calda e vabbè mi farò
la doccia fredda e pazienza me ne faccio
una ragione io non ho toccato un cazzo
che poi danno la colpa a me mi fa a
ripagare le cose [ __ ] ma è
crollato pure il muro dietro il boiler
ma chi l'ha vista
non avevo dubbi che ci sarebbe stato del
sangue sento delle cascate del niagara
complimenti ma posso posso farmi la
doccia
devo buttarmi giù e buttava se io devo
vivere dentro il sangue ragazzo è una
fissa questa no no aspetta fermi nati
ben venuto in mente non è che tornano
scott e prima verga lo squalo regalo
squadra lo sapevo ho la fobia di sal
sott'acqua ragazzi mi fa paura sta cosa
pre gara
li mortacci tua [ __ ] niente tua
sorella frottola la gara è stato
basta infatti mi toglie resta me non no
sott'acqua no è certo ragazzi concluso
viene fissa mica sembra un pazzo maniaco
così i capelli e sta camicia perfetto
spero che a video vi sia piaciuto perché
io non ne posso basta per ora dopo lo
strip basta cosa sento ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto lasciato momento mi piace anche
a pace di facebook come nei video tratta
l'ascrizione sul serio restituiscimi
diavolo prossimo vinto belle ragazze